hallo mein name ist mister pickel
herzlich willkommen wir heute zur ersten
whatsapp verfolgen seit 1843 und ich
würde sagen wir fangen direkt an mit dem
ersten teil und verschreibt er eine
person hydro ist ein bro antwortet er
schreibt daraufhin what are you doing
und sein freund antwortete daraufhin gut
und dir an der stelle würde ich dir
einfach empfehlen sprachen lernen
das hier ist der nächste woche fällt und
verschickt einer diesen smiley hier das
war doch noch gute alte zeiten wo man
smileys nicht als e mail verschickt hat
sondern in der auf jeden fall schickt er
diesen smiley und sein kumpel schreibt
wie machst du das spiegelverkehrte b
wahrte vergiss es ja
das spiegelverkehrte bero ich sitze hier
gerade im unterricht und wir schreiben
einen vokabeltest weißt was
bürgermeister heißt auf englisch burger
king
sag mal was auf chinesisch bonjour
das ist englisch student könnt ihr euch
beide bitte einfach verpissen charts tom
feiert seinen geburtstag am freitag kann
ich da hin nein da haben wir schon was
vorhat eine deiner freundin geburtstag
und ich sitze da wieder als einziger
mann nein deine tochter wird ein jahr
alt stimmt
der preis für den besten fall
kombi wächst kunden christine auf einer
skala von eins bis zehn wie gerne
diskutierst du geh doch 11 nein warum
nicht
ja
halfar auszudiskutieren bruder du bist
ein m taler oder wie das heißt was
meinst du denn da die höhlenmenschen
neandertaler auch dir kann ich empfehlen
denn eigentlich müssten sich die gründer
von babbel langsamer bezahlte linda tag
haben nur manchmal empfangen lieben dich
bis freitag mama und papa
also wenn nämlich nur bis freitag liebt
bleib ich hier ich glaube sie wollten
dann noch immer zwischen setzen aber
ältere leute haben es irgendwie in die
höhe
bist du gerade in der stadt innenstadt
auf dem weg zum markt warum dreh dich
mal oben was denn da ist nix weiter
links schauen wir genauer wo nicht
soweit legen ist meine güte ja was soll
denn da sein bist du hier nee ich sitze
in der uni mir ist langweilig und fand
die vorstellung lustig wie du dich in
der öffentlichkeit bleiben jetzt und
gassen weiter lieben freunde könnt eins
zu eins lukla sei also summa summarum
juckt und wisst ihr was auch eins zu
eins luca sein könnte wenn er jetzt
einfach werbung für seinen job machen
würde meine lieben freunde am 21.2 in
paar tagen kommt um 15 uhr er sich dass
ihr in den shop das ist eine
autogrammkarte sondern die bekommt ihr
zu der die kinder hätten wahrscheinlich
gar nichts zu sehen ist so richtig
punkten
dieses kissen hier wird es am 21 2 ab 15
uhr lukas abgeben wir produzieren
allerdings nur 1000 stück also better be
fest und jeder der ein kissen bestellt
und bekommt bekommt auch eine
handsignierte autogrammkarte von mir wo
ich der hässliche penner drauf bin und
das kissen in der hand halte
[Musik]
ja das hat super geklappt
allerdings weiter mit dem nächsten
whatsapp fällt uns verschreibt eine
person gestern bin ich vom stuhl
gefallen und hat mir das bein gebrochen
ich liege jetzt im krankenhaus und seine
mutter antwortet ist dem stuhl was
passiert schon mal so einen ähnlichen
whatsapp felder ging es allerdings
glaube ich um einen teppich und hatte
die mutter auch so geschrieben oder der
typ hatte erst geschrieben hätte wenn
man arm gebrochen oder irgendwie so und
die mutter los geht's mit dem teppich ok
unter flecken drauf und das sind einfach
mütter allgemeine
apropos mit park ich weiß ja wenn wir
bei instagram folglich heißt der laser
luca aber schaute auf jeden fall gerne
mal vorbei und schaut euch das story
highlight allein zu haus an
da war ich nämlich erst dann bei meiner
familie in bielefeld alleine zu hause
und habe so viele sachen entdeckt so
schilder von meiner mutter hat papa ware
so typische mutter sachen allerdings
will ich gar nicht weiter werbung machen
für meinen shop oder instagram oder
keine ahnung was andere machen weiter
mit diesem whatsapp hey du bist die
beste coolste und schönste schwester der
welt du bist einfach der engel in meinem
leben die viel willst du das ist das war
ich dann früher wenn ich meiner
schwester was geschrieben habe und
irgendwas haben wollte heute im
deutschkurs saß moritz neben mir der hat
mich total böse angepinkelt war die
eklig wieso erzählst du mir sowas marin
ein momentan gefunkelt angeflogen
marie sprachenlernen die frage will ich
nicht und hey du hast ja eben was ist
das denn bitte für ein name ich heiße
nicht eben du hast da ein paar vergessen
eving opa du tust mir echt leid die
gerade eben ksf kind meine fresse
herrschers wo bleibst du denn gerade hat
ein auto neben ihr angehalten der typ da
drin ruft mich an und fährt nicht weg
hilfe ich bin der der hut
es müsste echt mal ein video geben bei
dem ich nicht klatsche beim nächsten
mortzfeld schreibt der liebe leon seiner
schwester eine nachricht und zwar was
hältst du eigentlich von unserem blasen
finde die harte arbeit hat sich voll
gelohnt
leon du bist mein bruder was auch immer
du mir sagen möchtest las ich wollte den
rasen
du musst wissen was du willst pommes ich
meine auf lange sicht viele pommes an
der stelle würde ich eigentlich nur
sagen was willst du mal einen
zaubertrick sehen ja klar ob du bist
single
[Musik]
das ist eine starke art und weise um
eine beziehung zu beenden
in der woche bei diesem nächsten
bortfeld fragt ein typ seinen kollegen
wo bleibst du und dieser antwortet warte
eine sekunde
ich bin in einer minute da das könnte
richtig wieder ich sein
ich bin stolz
nicht so ermöglichte mensch summarum
juckt aber im endeffekt niemand bro
stiegler mediamarkt iphone kaufen kaufst
du fünf oder sechs nur eins man was
durch mit 506 iphones machen wolle
bruder was hat das sprachenlernen lukasz
man die sala dein profilbild ist schön
ich habe doch gar keins das ist ja das
schöne daran
welchen film habt ihr euch eigentlich
angeschaut ps ich liebe dich ich dich
auch ich meine so hieß der film ja ja
ist das unangenehm was auch unangenehm
ist es wenn du diese nachrichten bekommt
und zwar okay also so langsam kannst du
aufhören mit was am besten mit atmen
ich werde hier fürs klar
mama kriege ich ein bisschen geld denkst
du geldwechsel aufbäumen woraus besteht
geld papier woraus mit papier gemacht
blätter wohin blätter der menschen
ziemlich abgestoßen beim nächsten watts
im fell berichtet eine person seiner
freundin von einem feuchten traum den er
hatte uns vorschreibt
ich hatte gestern einen feuchten traum
mit dir hahahahaha erzählt du wurdest
von einem bus überfahren und ich habe
mich vor lachen bibb ist
[Musik]
ich
jetzt denkt
bei sowas halt wirklich einfach nur noch
einen neuen augen habe und beim nächsten
whatsapp fällt schreibt ebenfalls ein
junge an seine freundin ich habe gehört
dass du auf böse jungs stehst oh ja und
wie also ich will ich jetzt nicht
irgendwie beeindrucken aber als ich als
kleines kind immer die kleinen einsteins
geschaut habe und dass dabei hieß man
soll dreimal in die hände klatschen habe
ich immer viermal geklatscht
ich habe fünfmal geklatscht um mein gott
bin ich ein fettes hätte ich das halb
sprachenlernens mal kurz überlegen
wollen wir nun allerdings auch zum
letzten whatsapp fällt für die heutige
folge meiner lieben freund und zwar
bekommt dort jemand diese nachricht
kannst du mir ein paar bilder schicken
ich habe dich schon welche per mail
geschickt ach ja wie heißt die den
träumen weiter du idiot gmail.com ok ich
sehe mal nach und an der stelle meine
lieben freunde welche das heutige video
auch beenden wenn euch diese heute
wirklich nach 376 milliarden jahren neu
hochgeladene folge jfl dieser stehe ich
ja eigentlich so gefallen hat liefert
wie bereits gesagt launch dieses kissen
am 21 zweiter also meinen geburtstag um
15 uhr in lucka - shop.de schaut dort
gern vor bei jeder bestellung bekommt
eine handsignierte autogrammkarte von
mir was sagt das laserschwerter zu ja
wenn ihr noch kein abonnent zeit von
diesem intellektuelle hochwertigen kanal
dann klickt ja noch abonnieren wenn wir
schlafen und dann klickt auf die glocke
ich kann es euch allerdings wirklich
nicht empfehlen
[Musik]